lo que quiero que hagas en este vídeo es
ponerle pausa y pensar en cuánto es 27
menos 1 y cuánto es 27 menos 10 muy bien
tal vez te pareció que la respuesta es
muy directa pero quiero que pensemos en
esto en términos de valores posicionales
empecemos por aquí con el 27 que se
conforma de 12 en el lugar de las
decenas de escena y por aquí podemos ver
estas dos decenas estos dos grupos de 10
unidades y también tenemos 7 unidades
porque aquí están las siete unidades
pero a este 27 le estamos restando un 1
nunca y este 1 pues es una unidad porque
tenemos un 1 en el lugar de las unidades
unidades así es que lo que tenemos que
hacer es quitar una de estas unidades
aunque la voy a quitar así y entonces
ahora cuanto tenemos
bueno pues las decenas se quedaron
intactas lo que tenemos dos decenas dos
decenas
pero ahora cuántas unidades tenemos
bueno pues antes teníamos 7 unidades y
quitamos una entonces nos quedan 6
unidades
unidades así es que dos decenas y seis
unidades ya eso le llamamos 26 bueno y
ahora vamos con 27 menos 10 otra vez
tenemos por aquí 27 que son dos decenas
y siete unidades dos decenas y siete
unidades pero ahora no vamos a restar
ninguna unidad y vamos a restar una
decena que hay aquí tenemos un 1 en el
lugar de las decenas
y una decenas son 10 unidades y puede
sonar un poco chistoso como que estoy
repitiendo la misma cosa una y otra vez
pero realmente me interesa que entiendas
muy bien esto del valor posicional ok
este es el lugar de las decenas y aquí
tenemos una decena aunque claro que cada
decena son 10 unidades
así es que aquí estamos restando una
decena y cero unidades entonces pues
vamos a quitar esta decena quitamos una
decena y ahora con que nos quedamos con
cuantas decenas nos quedamos pues aquí
tenemos un grupo de diez unidades una
decena
una decena este es el lugar de las
decenas y cuántas unidades nos quedan
pues nos siguen quedando siete unidades
entonces ponemos un siete en el lugar de
las unidades unidades entonces 27 menos
10 es una decena y 7 unidades o sea 17 y
bueno otra forma en la que pudimos haber
hecho esto y qué tal vez fue la forma
que tuvo utilizaste para calcular estas
restas es decir ok tenemos 27 y le
queremos restar una unidad lo que tengo
que hacer es irme al lugar de las
unidades y restarle 1 y entonces vamos
de 27 a 26 pero si ahora a 27 le
quitamos una decena entonces es en el
lugar de las decenas en el que vamos a
disminuir 1 lo que íbamos a ir de 27 a
17 lo que estamos pasando de 12 en el
lugar d
decenas a 11 en el lugar de las decenas
y en lugar de las unidades no cambió
nada